so what kind of music does your band
play
you know i don't really like to define
it but it's like um matchbox 20 meets
the fray
so
rock well again i don't really like to
define it so undefinable rock you know
again the term rock i think defines it i
totally got what you mean marco
[Music]
polo
marco
polo
marco
polo
marco
i wonder what they're doing right now
probably making out on top of a deer
carcass
super
romantic you know if i give you a hickey
it would totally make i'm jealous we
should grab a drink after this at
tucker's
yeah i would do that
that sounds fun
it says right here you're 20.
you're not even gonna show me a fake
sometimes the confidence confuses people
you're good bro you know what i think
i'll just i'm gonna
um i know another bar that always lets
me
uh
yeah actually i should be going home
peruse this wondrous book at your
leisure and take advantage of everything
this great town has to offer
time is fleeting my fellow pawneeans
make the most of it while you can
i like you
in a
you know
romantical kind of way you do
yes
do you
like me yes
so then
perhaps
shall we go out this evening
no
i don't think we should see each other
oh
damn it because you're 21 and i'm 29 no
i don't care about that
it's because whenever i see you talk to
anne or talk about anne i feel like you
still have feelings for her what no i
don't
listen what i said this afternoon was
stupid
okay i totally want to go out with you
good
i want to be with you
here's just one thing real quick i want
to be totally honest with you because i
like you so much but like two minutes
ago me and ann did kiss
what oh you think that i'm a jerk but i
hope you can forgive me
gross your forehead is all sweaty that's
gross
i still like you
okay oh that's disgusting
if you do everything i hate for a month
then i might begin to think about the
possibility of thinking about maybe
staying that's all i have to hear how
did it go today it was super fun it was
yeah do you have a list for tomorrow
you want to do this again tomorrow yes i
do i mean it's a deal right i got to do
it for a whole month and then you're not
going to move to indianapolis
hey i love you
dude shut up that is awesome sauce
andy she's mad because you said awesome
sauce instead of i love you too april he
loves you stop being a child tom you're
clearly at fault here blaming jerry
won't save you jerry
we both know you were shotgunning funnel
cakes instead of watching lil sebastian
so everyone apologized to everyone else
i'm sorry tommy sorry
i do love you
you do
yeah
that's what you know makes the sauce so
awesome
we are gathered here today to marry
andrew maxwell dwyer and april roberta
ludgate
i guess i
kind of hate most things but i never
really seem to hate you
so
i want to spend the rest of my life with
you is that cool
[Music]
you can ask me
[Music]
it's so much more beautiful than i could
have ever even imagined
yeah
trying to find a way to be annoyed by it
but
coming up empty
thank you so much
i never would have ever done this
without you
thank you
where's all the faces
the presidents
hi
champion champion champion oh my gosh
there you are puppy
that is a three-legged dog his name is
champion
cause he's the dog world champion okay i
have to ask this i'm sorry but how many
legs did that dog have when you found
him my amazing lover ben wyatt is here
working on a congressional campaign and
he took april with him as his intern
hey
oh
so great to see you too
yikes
okay uh guys let's motor
guys
guys let's go get some astronaut ice
cream or something we were thinking
about maybe just
uh we maybe we were going to go back
here okay
april here's something to help you
remember our three-legged dog champion
oh that's cute also you are way better
at laundry can you please do mine and
send it back to me thanks love you
mouserat rules love andy less cute p.s
please hurry i've been wearing a bandana
as underwear for three days now look
there's a picture
ah
that's horrifying
i love him so much
a while ago i applied to veterinary
school in bloomington and i just found
out that
i got in you did
that's amazing wait why did you wait to
tell me because i don't even know if i
want to go okay
i mean yes it's been my dream to work
with animals since i was a kid and
everything but
it would mean i'd be spending a lot of
time apart from you and oh we could get
through that
i mean look it would suck for a while
and i would miss you while you're gone
but
as i've known about you
for the past 20 seconds
this is your dream
i'm really glad i married you yeah we
made a good call on that one
i want you to stay here in london with
me for no more than three months to help
me get it up and running and tell me
what to do
i want andy to stay
is that a goose he said he wanted me to
head up the company i have no idea how
to run a nonprofit hey
you shined shoes for over two years and
never made a profit
come on you can hack this
i believe in you my god what are you
doing here i just missed you so bad
honey i bought myself a ticket home
you're never gonna need that computer
again
deep down everyone is just faking it
until they figure it out
and you will too because you are awesome
and everyone else sucks
andy got back from london two days ago
and he still has jet lag
oh my god are you kidding me
andy
we are planning our whole week like old
people we used to be spontaneous and
weird we used to eat cereal a lot of
frisbees because we didn't have any
bowls that's it
we've held out as long as we could but
it finally happened we're boring so this
place has had zero offers people seem to
be scared off
on account of it being haunted
and disgusting
we are responsible adults
you know what that means i know we have
money and we are going to buy the
out of this house seriously yes i want
to work here
at the foundation it's definitely the
job i wanted
but
it means that we have to move to
washington you're doing what you're
meant to do and i can't be the person
that makes you lose what you love but
you're what i love you're the only
reason i have any of this some thieves
are trying to steal the legendary
snakehole sapphire what the no it's just
seeing all those kids out there
babe
i want to put a babe in you baby
so april's still on the fence about kids
you have kids
because you and andy are a team
and you want to bring in some new team
members
here comes a contraction are you ready
okay i'm ready let's do this
[Music]
bert macklin jr
um we need a halloween angle how about
demon spawn baby satan dwyer oh i like
that yeah or
uh maybe bert snakehole
ludgate
karate dracula macklin demon
jack-o'-lantern dwyer we call him jack
for short
you